But yeah, back to my school trip to America,
it was my first time ever going to America. Right. And, uh,
I remember those two things. I was really excited for going to America,
which I think they were in and out. No, I didn't go there.
I only went to New York and went to New York, the food.
I wanted two things from what I'd seen from media. I want to Twinkies.
I wanted mountain dude, not a mountain doing UK. They do,
but it's not like it's the stuff without like the green stuff in it,
because that, that stuff's illegal in the UK. So our mountain,
our mountain dude just tastes like Sprite. What we have, we have it,
but it's not that popular. And it doesn't taste like mountain Dew at all.
Really proper mountain day.
What the is in mountain Dew that makes it illegal in the UK.
The stuff that makes it super green, really.
Like, cause I'm pretty sure like all the sodas in the UK,
you're not allowed to use corn syrup either.
Like in a ma like Coke and soda in America tastes different from like sodas in
the UK. In fact, those have less sugar in it as well. It has,
it has like a little less sugar and you can taste it. You can,
you can definitely taste.
I had like proper mountain Dew or I guess now I know is proper mountain Dew in
America was like, I'll show you. I might have different. It might not,
but Twinkies, Twinkies or.
Why did you think it was good?
Cause in all the TV shows they made Twinkies look amazing.
And then I had to wait. Yeah. And I'm like, from what TV show,
like zombie land actually. Cause he's obsessed with them in zombie land.
Oh yeah. I also learned that they were like, can survive nuclear or something.
Yeah. I don't think that's, I don't think that's true at all. But in family guy,
I wonder how much Twinkies paid zombie land. Like that was fantastic.
That was like five head advertised.
I went there as a teenager and I just want it.
This spongy thing that you put into your mouth, survival food during it,
during apocalypse, by God. So like I.
Prone to getting like nosebleeds as well. Uh, until I got my nose cauterized.
All right. Which is like, when you get like Burnett. Yeah. Um,
so I was getting used to it. If it got like even remotely hot,
I would get nosebleeds really. So when I went to America,
it was just too hot in the summer and I was just everyday.
I had nose bleeds a lot. Doesn't get in New York in the summer. It's pretty hot.
I remember I went to.
Once in the summer and it was like pretty hot and humid.
Like in the thirties. I don't know why I thought,
because it's the so-called in the window. I would assume we'd get,
got like quite cool in the summer. It was great though.
Cause any of the like really boring places, I would just be like,
come on and then just I'd get to go get ice cream or something.
Just Africa take me out.
Cause we were like going through like a one museum that was really boring.
I can't remember. It was as a kid because she was the big museum in New York.
Now the Smithsonian was pretty cool.
Cause that was like loads of exhibits and stuff.
There's some other museum they took us to, which was like,
maybe it was like the some CIA thing that was like books. And I was like,
I have no interest in this. I, but I remember I had no interest. They just like,
let us go around times square on our own [inaudible] that.
Could have gone horrendously. Yeah.
Yeah. Like, like time square. Like.
I'm not even.
I wouldn't let my 60 door. I don't even feel it.
During the day in times square little at a night. I didn't feel safe. As,
as an adult there let alone like a 16 year old kid.
And I remember this funny.
One of the kids came back, right. I need to punch a CDs. And we were like,
why do you have CDs? He's like, Oh, well, uh,
the guys kept coming up to me and telling me if I wanted to hear them spit.
So I kept having to buy them for $5. And I was like,
you know that the dudes carts you're like, yo, he's my mix tape.
He was paying every time for everyone that came up to him.
So he's just all of these like, mixed sex.
I don't remember what I did. I think I just went around all the stores.
You'd looked at it and be like, wow, it's just so strange.
It would go in like M and M world and be like, wow,
I can't afford any of it because it would be like $10 for a pack of M and M.
So I'm like, wow, I'm really broke. Huh?
My parents really didn't give me M and M's
I remember as well I'll hotel. Right. They put us in, like,
I think it was like the sun in, what is that called?
It's like the comfort in or something. That's what it's called.
The sun got like a son Logan. Yeah.
And I remember we were all baffled because the only thing they had for breakfast
was like burgers. That could be microwave. And it was disgusting.
We were all like, yeah. American food. We ate it with like, Oh, American food.
It's like some white castle. Yeah.
It was gross. Um, I remember as well that, uh,
we had to get the bus everywhere and it was just the worst because they tried to
fit. Like they, they use public buses like private coaches.
Talking the more I'm realizing why,
who decided to go on a school trip to New York.
I think it was what must have been one teacher that really.
It mentioned this that they do.
So we would go on like the public buses,
like the whole like 40 kids would go on a normal public bus.
It was already full it's terrifying. And then all the,
all the dudes were like topless on the bus. And we were like, Oh God, Oh God,
I'm in danger. And then when the teachers would all go to bed,
all the kids just went out at night. And we went in because we were obviously,
we were like not a rich school at all.
So like the really sketchy part of New York.
But you're rich enough to go to New York though.
Not really. It was,
I remember the whole trip for like four or five days with flights and five
hotels was like 800 pounds and everything was taken for like.
I guess.
Very budget, very budget. So the hotels we stayed in, what? Life?
Not good at all.
Like in the ghetto.
They were like, Halla. Imagine it you've got like 40 just like white school.
Kids that have no idea what's going on. But.
They break out at night and I'm like, I get it. But it's like.
Oh God, you guys are like Harlem or something.
I can't remember where we were, but we were very far away.
It was at a 40 minute bus journey into town that could have been anywhere
sketchy. I think we were like Queens.
Maybe we might've been around somewhere like that. It was definitely.
I remember that. I remember having these cars,
you would see on the movies that New York was like, yeah, man. It's bustling.
It's yeah. I was like, why is where we're staying?
Everything is boarded up and dirty. What's up with that?
Hustling bustling is like two blocks and men.
Well, I, I distinctly remember.
I really didn't like New York and I liked DC because when we went to DC,
it was really nice. And I remember that,
cause I was just scared when we went to New York.
That was, that was mine. First impression going to New York as well.
I also went when I was a bit older. So I was like 20.
I feel like when you're 60 and 22, that way you see the waters completely.
Yeah. I don't know. I still have this, like, you know, the, the,
the American film image of New York. And I was,
I remember my first time going there. I remember thinking, man,
there's a lot of street corners that I've never seen in any films that look
pretty dodgy.
As well. Like Spider-Man's parents got killed.
That's the thing. When I went to New York, like four or five years ago,
like it was really good. If as long as your neck was like above like landscape,
right. It's just like, wow, these buildings look really good.
And the moment you look down and just like, Oh, that's a lot of trash.
There is that. That was my first impression.
There is a lot of trash that just has never, it has never appeared on,
like there was no trash on this corner that is like reaching like traffic
lights, like my God go to Chinatown for the first time
don't hit there for the smell differently.
This is episode 33 where we clown on America.